rudy giuliani who was at one point known
as mayor 911 who presided over the city
of new york as its mayor during and in
the immediate aftermath of the 9 11
attacks
appeared on real america's voice with dr
gina now we'll get to this dr gina thing
in a second why why is she dr gina and
why what kind of a doctor is she
pay really close attention to this clip
rudy giuliani does not reject 9 11
conspiracies
in this interview when the host floats
listen i'm not that conspiratorial
but i'm starting to wonder about some of
these conspiracy theories about 9 11
myself
and rudy rather than rejecting out of
hand those conspiracy theories which
relate to an event that happened in new
york while he was governor i'm sorry
mayor of new york city
um he sort of says yeah there's lots of
stuff that i didn't believe which turned
out to be true uh check this out and pay
really close attention to the language
being used here
and mayor i guess i just i have to ask
you this because it struck me yesterday
as i as i looked through the post you
know you always see
all the posts on social media on
september 11th and and and rightly so we
should absolutely remember and never
forget but i noticed a sincere
strong uptick
and the number of folks asking about
things that have traditionally been
painted conspiracy theories regarding
september 11th and i noticed a lot of
people saying things like uh that is
disrespectful to those who've died and
those who've suffered to ask any
questions about it but i also know mayor
not only did you live through 911 you've
been a target of the federal government
um
you've been one of those people who has
been persecuted one of the 50 or more we
know at this point
persecuted basically for doing your job
um and being friends with the president
um so i just so understand the
connection that's being drawn here okay
dr gina says listen
uh
i'm not big on these 911 conspiracy
theories but
i'm now starting to be a little more
sympathetic to the 911s conspiracy
theory people
because similarly there are people who
said things about you mr mayor that
turned out to be untrue as well and so
if those uh those things were wrong
maybe the conspiracy theorists about 911
are right that's what dr gina is saying
now by the way let's talk and we're
going to continue with the clip dr gina
this is gina louden
she's known as dr gina she's just a
right-wing media personality now you
might remember
when it was dr jill biden all of these
right-wingers were saying that's not a
medical doctor
why are they calling her dr jill biden
that's absolutely crazy she's a doctor
of education
um
dr gina
has a phd
in human and organization systems
from fielding graduate university which
is an online school now there's nothing
wrong with online school or any of it
but
that doctorate
is completely irrelevant to her role as
the host of the dr gina show
just so many people might not even know
this rachel maddow
um was a rhodes scholar
and has a doctorate of philosophy
in politics
from the university of oxford okay
it would still be a bit much to say dr
rachel maddow the dr rachel maddow show
although i would argue that her
defil in politics from oxford
is more relevant and more impressive
than what makes gina lauden a doctor
but
where were they when it was dr jill
biden's degree shouldn't be mentioned
but yet now it's the dr gina show it's
absurd and you'll actually hear rudy
refer to her as doctor which is just
like the cherry on top i i guess
i kind of was thinking yesterday i
i don't believe the things that i've
read about that but i
i don't fault people anymore for asking
questions that may sound outlandish when
our government is a proven enemy of some
people oh mary i wanted to give you a
chance to speak to this yeah well you
know uh uh doctor that's really um
[ __ ]
up
why does it feel absurd for him to refer
to her as doctor in this context i find
myself now
uh
saying things and realizing they're true
that if i had said them five years ago i
would have thought i was crazy right i
mean i would have well we think you're
crazy now for saying but right uh let's
take russian collusion
that a political party would spend a
couple million dollars to make up a
charge
to frame
a candidate for president
then to try to frame a president
and remove him on a charge that was
purchased and as a complete line
carry it on for four or five years and
have the support of the american press
i would have said that's crazy that
can't happen that can't possibly happen
the press will be outraged they'll go
nut and once they found out that it was
a complete fraud
they just go on to the next fraud the
whole thing with the ukraine which
turned out to be another fraud and then
they go on to suppress
the uh the hard drive which contains
so basically what rudy is saying is
instead of dr gina
let me be very clear doctor
dr gina did i mention doctor
i was mayor of 9 11 when that happened
and what took place on that day
is that
more than a dozen
uh men
mostly saudis
attacked us
and they flew two planes and then
another one crashed in pennsylvania you
know
then the three fine um
he doesn't do that
he instead says hey listen
uh i know what you're saying about maybe
these conspiracy theorists are right
there was the russia thing and then
there was the ukraine thing as he says
it and on and on and on he is not
rejecting the idea that the 911
conspiracy theories may be true he was
mayor of of new york during 9 11.
and he now
and again i don't actually think rudy
believes any of the conspiracy theories
i think rudy knows exactly what happened
on 9 11 the way the way we've all gotten
to the bottom of it as donald trump says
we have not
but he has been so sucked in by this
just vile right-wing movement
non-thinking movement
that this is the answer that he has to
give it's a sad state of affairs
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack offering low sugar plant-based keto
friendly bars i love these they are the
perfect snack for anyone trying to eat
better or cutting back on sugar and
carbs without sacrificing taste
monk pack offers granola bars and nut
and seed bars each with only one gram of
sugar or less two to three net carbs and
150 calories or less i'm a big fan of
the macadamia white chocolate nut and
seed bar
great combination of sweet salty chewy
and crunchy and there's under one gram
of sugar they come in other awesome
flavors like sea salt dark chocolate
coconut cocoa chip and caramel sea salt
monk pack is great if you're doing keto
i don't do keto but monk pack is just
great for anyone who wants something
delicious on the go without the sugar
and my audience gets 20 off your first
order at monkpack.com when you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout the link
is down below